the goal is not to get the person to buy
the goal is to get the person to decide
and if we can do that you can sell
whatever you want people blame
circumstances other people and then
ultimately themselves and so when we're
overcoming obstacles in a sale we have
to make sure that we are taking away
time taking away money as a reason they
can't do it we have to make sure that
they don't cast their power to other
people and saying I can't make this
decision someone else has to make it and
then finally when they're with
themselves they want to avoid the
decision and you have to basically sift
through the crap that they're telling
themselves about why they can't decide
and so if you can structure a
conversation that way it's not it's
value additive and then ultimately you
do make more money but you're not
focused on that because you're focused
on helping them make the call